whoa before we get started I want to go
over the four sponsors for this episode
who make all this possible
they're fantastic so go show them some
love the first is the best URL in the
industry crypto comm their crypto
platform with one goal driving mass
adoption that's why we're all here right
to get every human on earth a digital
wallet and to get them using digital
currencies crypto comms helping people
do that through buying earning lending
and a new card payment everything you
could want is at crypto calm they've
been longtime supporters of
off-the-chain and recently announced a
new exchange so go help them out
download their app from the App Store or
visit crypto comm and tell them pom sent
you there's nothing better in the world
than a company helping to drive global
adoption of this new technology another
part of global adoption is making sure
that we secure the various block chains
with computing power coin mine has built
the best consumer experience in mining
hands-down no competition if you want to
help secure the blockchain and get
started in mining you can go to coin
mine comm slash pop order a coin mine
it'll arrive at your door
and you simply take it out of the box
plug it in and connect to your Wi-Fi
you'll be mining your favorite crypto in
five minutes or less it is honestly
magical I have one running right now
here in the office and it's super quiet
it's got no heat and every person that
comes in the office asks what is that
every single person asks it's a coin
mine the best part to me is that the
coin mine comes with a mobile app that's
super slick and the company continues to
push over-the-air updates to the device
that add functionality ad tokens that
can be mine or increase the efficiency
of the device similar to how Tesla does
car software updates over the air
coin mines sending these passively to
thousands of coin mines around the world
on a periodic basis pretty damn cool
when far booed and the team pitched me
on the idea of an Xbox or Playstation
like box that could mine cryptocurrency
in your home I was immediately sold I
invested in the business have a device
personally and keep telling people to go
to coin mine comm / pump so they can
save a lot of time if they want to get
started mining today in coin mine has a
partnership with our third sponsor for
this episode block 5 block 5 is one of
my favorite companies in crypto because
they allow users to deposit their assets
in a deposit account and immediately
start earning interest think about it if
you keep your digital assets on an
exchange or in cold storage you aren't
benefiting from any yield on the
asset with block fie they allow you to
deposit crypto and then get paid
interest on a monthly basis in crypto
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in eath you can do it
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in Bitcoin you can do
it the rates have block fire are
currently some of the best in the
industry
you can earn six percent interest on
Bitcoin and you can earn up to eight
point six percent 8py on G USD deposits
I'm an investor in the company and think
block fights building really important
and compelling infrastructure so go
check them out at block fire comm slash
pump again this block five comm slash
pump and that brings us to the last
advertiser of the episode eToro these
guys have absolutely crushed it over the
years their founder yoni was one of the
original Bitcoin OGIS that has been
ahead of almost every trend in crypto he
built eToro to help people buy sell and
trade crypto currencies but he added a
few twists social trading copy trading
and virtual trading accounts social
trading is a feature where every asset
available on the platform has its own
separate social feed where people talk
about the asset share trading ideas and
analysis and even include various charts
or graphs virtual trading accounts is
targeted at beginners if you're just
starting out and want to try trading
with play money eToro will give you a
virtual account with $100,000 in it to
test learn and get comfortable and so
then that brings us to copy trading
which is by far the coolest feature this
allows you as a user to select any other
users portfolio to copy if you see
someone on the platform you like you can
set your account to mimic their trades
they buy Bitcoin with 5% of their
portfolio your portfolio buys 5% Bitcoin
they sell 50% of their ether position
your portfolio does the same thing
automatically copy trading is awesome so
go join the 10 plus million other
traders on eToro and start trading all
the most popular cryptocurrencies today
they're one of the largest companies in
the space and you can get started by
going to e Toro comm again that is eToro
comm where the entire team is ready to
get you started in just a few clicks and
don't forget go subscribe to the
off-the-chain daily newsletter you can
go to off-the-chain sub stack comm I
write a letter of news analysis and
opinion every morning that goes out to
more than 40000 investors see you there
what's up everyone this is Anthony pop
Leon Oh most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off the Shah Shetty is the
founder and CEO of Wozniak's one of the
most popular crypto exchanges in India
was ear X was recently acquired by
finance in this conversation we
discussed in the Sholes journey to
crypto what it is like building startups
in India the current state of crypto in
the country how regulators are currently
thinking about the industry and the
shawls advice to both people looking to
serve Indian users or Indians who are
looking into crypto mr. Hall has been a
friend for a number of years and I
couldn't be happier for him and his team
with the recent acquisition I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well Anthony pomp lion-o is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pomp or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek Digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I have nasaw
calling in from from India super excited
to have this conversation him and I have
have known each other not for a number
of years and obviously recently was
announced that finance is acquiring his
company so thanks so much for taking the
time during a busy time period for you
two to come on and talk happy to be on
the show pump I think we've been trying
to get this done for a while both of us
to finally glad to be here on the show
for sure let's just start with with your
background I you on a trip to India kind
of pre crypto so maybe just kind of
everyone in on what you did before you
discovered a Bitcoin cryptograph sure I
think yeah we met because of my first
target
I started this back in 2012
it's called crowdfire and
social media management tool before it
was a social media management tool it
was a social media growth tool where we
allowed users to you know grow on social
networks using various growth features
that we had but along the way you know
all these social networks as they grew
they wanted to keep all the money to
themselves so they change the api's and
now we've made it a social media
management tool and crowd far has had
over 20 million uses until now it's it
was during its time when I had launched
it it was one of the most viral apps
around in 2012-2013 1040 so yep I
started with that before I started my
startup I was working at another startup
in India which got acquired and then you
know a few of us we started our own side
projects and that's how my side project
grew to be crowdfire and I quit my job
then after building crowdfire I raised
some venture capital VI raised about two
and a half million dollars for that and
grew it for the grew the team size and
stuff
from there I'll you know do you want me
to tell about how do I bendito crypto
from there so one of the things with
crowdfire that was so interesting to me
is when when we met I came to the office
and I remember not really understanding
or having expectation as to you know a
start-up in India could go a lot of
different ways from the perspective of
somebody from the United States and what
struck me was not only I think kind of
the size of the team and the quality of
the people that you had hired but even
just the office itself right you had
built a fairly palatial and kind of
office environment that reminded me a
lot of Silicon Valley startups right and
so it was pretty cool to see have the
culture that you were building there
even though you know literally halfway
across the world a lot of the same
things that people would see in a
Silicon Valley startup were being
implemented you know in your
organization which I thought was pretty
I still remember you coming in and then
you know being surprised and telling me
that this looked more like a office in
the valley rather than in India but I
think you know having build products for
a global audience I always believe that
it's important to imbibe all of the
stuff not just your product but the way
you work with your people around you to
be you you know the workplace even the
information you consume if you want to
build something global you need to be
global right from your core and I think
that was the principle that's led me to
ensure that you know we are not just
just product wise we inaudible but be a
global in terms of a thought process so
I think it all boils down to that you
know the core belief being if you want
to build for the world be citizen of the
world
so yeah that's that's how all of this
happened I guess the office the people
and then when was the first time that
you came across Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency so my journey has been
more of an on and off in in 2000 I think
this was late 2009 or early 2010 when I
came across the whole Bitcoin white
paper and because I be I was someone who
used to read a lot online try everything
new so I specifically remember trying to
mine Bitcoin I don't know what happened
after that
but I I had sold off that computer after
year or two because I bought a new
laptop so I don't even remember whether
I mined any or how much I might because
it all went in that computer that I sold
but that was just a you know trial and
error that I was trying back that
because it was so new and I left it I
never thought that Bitcoin would be what
it is then after that episode I think it
was 2013 or something 2012 or 2013 when
I tried on all these new set of your
crypto wallet that were coming online
including coinbase at that time and a
couple of more so I that was my second
stint with Bitcoin where and this time I
you know transfer some bitcoins to my
friends they
them to me so that's how I tried it
again but then again I think after a
couple of months of just playing around
with that I left it the third the third
interaction was when you know I was
pulled down to the rabbit hole I would
say of Krypto that was 2017 probably the
middle of the year when Bitcoin was
about to break out and since then I've
been in it forever I think now for sure
and so when that was going on were the
coin bases and other kind of major
exchanges were they available in India
or were they only available outside no
they were not in India that said I I
think I remember the only way I could
get it was to a friend who sent it to me
and you know it was a small amount but
the way the friend could send it because
the friend was in the u.s. or somewhere
odd he got some payments I don't
remember exactly but I I don't think
there was a way to buy bitcoins in India
and 2012-2013 got it and in sue maybe
talk a little bit about how you
eventually came up with the idea for was
your ex and in kind of what you guys
built out of the gate initial yeah so
this was 2017 and you know surprisingly
even in 2017 while a few exchanges I had
cropped up in India none of them seemed
to be on par with the global products
you know and I've always like you know
this goes back the background what we
were just talking about building global
products yeah and when you use them and
then I used all these Indian exchanges
that existed I realized there was a
large disparity in the user experience
or the way they treated their customers
so this was like the biggest sharp pain
point I try buying crypto from quite a
few of the Indian exchanges in 2070 and
you know the biggest thing I saw was you
know the experience that I had on some
global platforms was his Indian it was a
large disparity and that was the biggest
motivation because me and
of my other colleagues also felt the
same you know disparity we said that the
Indian audiences and when we see the
potential of crypto India can play a
significant part which means you cannot
have a substandard product in the
country if you want to onboard everyone
to cut though so that was the motivation
which we took and said can we since we
built crowdfire which is global can we
build another product which can be
compared with other global products and
that's how we started this was late
December we the 27th in the idea
originated of let's build it we launched
finally in March 2018 when the bear
market just was starting I guess so yeah
it was a good transition when you decide
in the pull the bear comes what do you
do but because price was not the you
know the factor for us to get in it
never really was a concern for us we
still launched and kept growing for sure
and then maybe let's talk a little bit
about kind of the environment around
crypto currencies and watch-chain
technology in India right I think
there's a lot of kind of rumors that are
spreading especially outside of India
right so people who don't live there
there's people who believe that crypto
is banned there's people who think that
the government is you know literally
going to jail people who participate in
this but but you're living there and and
really kind of at the ground truth of
what's going on so maybe give us a
overview of what is the current
environment around
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency in it yeah I
think that's an excellent question and
you know there's a lot of confusion
around this but here's the thing if you
look at it from a legal or regulatory
point of view in India the only problem
that India faces in terms of crypto
today is the central bank of India which
is there is a back of it you are not
allowing crypto businesses to have bank
accounts which means they do not want
crypto businesses to accept money from
individuals
in terms of our government none of them
has given any negative or positive
statements so it's been more the
government lawmakers are more or less
neutral but the central bank has a
problem with crypto and I think the only
way to navigate that was to not have a
bank account still allow people to
participate in the whole crypto
ecosystem which we did with the
peer-to-peer way of you know buying and
selling crypto currencies but your as an
Indian citizen you are free to hold
crypto you're free to sell it you're
free to use it because the government
has not come up with any laws against it
but recently what what happened a few
months back is there was a draft bill
that was proposed which and the draft
bill was created by a committee that was
set up by our government in 2017 late
2070 and that committee recommends a ban
on crypto now what has to be seen is
that this committee is not like the
final authority to come up with anything
they were interested with a certain work
they did it and the committee does not I
don't think the committee sort of
exercycle because the head of the
committee was transferred to a different
department in India after the report but
yeah that's the only draft bill but if
you see in the media what happened is
the moment with draft bill came which
was very surprising honestly having been
working in crypto the last 20 months or
so I realized how news can be distorted
in different different ways before
crypto I never thought of news being
distorted all change but the moment this
draft was announced I saw a reports in
various media which said India bans
crypto India will people will be jailed
and sent to ten years in prison but
honestly this is just one of the many
drafts that can come out this might be a
draft which might never be even
discussed we do not know but this was
just a recommendation by a committee and
that was set up by the government it's
not the government's views or anything
got it in so let's stop first about
have the central bank saying hey if
you're a crypto company you can't work
with regulated financial institutions
right it's kind of going after the
dependency of the crypto industry on the
legacy financial system so that means
that as a crypto business you can't have
a bank account etc how as an
entrepreneur building a company or are
people getting over that obstacle right
like what do you do if if that is the
position that the central bank yeah I
think the the biggest problem is how do
you run your company in the country
there but the good news is if you do not
deal directly with users money the banks
are pretty much ok with you having a
bank account so the whole thing is if
you have a bank account and do not deal
with your customers directly through
that bank account there are banks which
are ok with it because then you become
just a software development form not a
crypto you know exchange so that's one
way well what Indian companies are doing
is they're creating bank accounts in
India only for salary payments not for
accepting deposits from their users or
you know processing any kind of fiat
related activities so that's like the
first the other what a lot of other
businesses are doing is they're
registering outside the country because
that's more straightforward easy made
and you know in whatever foreign
countries they register that becomes
their primary place of business so
that's the second way but yeah I think
these are the two popular ways either
you have a bank account in the country
but do not do any activities related to
crypto just salaries and vendor payments
then you're good to go
got it and then in terms of like paying
employees and things like that for most
of the employees either a 12-0 or other
crypto companies taking their salaries
in Fiat or they taking it in crypto like
how does that play into into the system
see I think ideally in terms of salaries
of Fiat is a better way in India because
there's a lot of processing you have to
in terms of tax deductions and souls and
stuff which if the company was to pay
you in crypto it becomes difficult
because the government does not accept
tax in anything apart from Ayana and as
a company if you were to convert that
like I said if you use your company bank
account for any crypto transactions like
even converting your own company's
crypto into Fiat you will have trouble
with the banks so fiat payments as
salaries is the safest way today I I
won't be surprised if I employees wanted
in crypto because so much more
convenient they don't want to probably
liquidate right away and just hold it
but I think from a company point of view
from a business point of view right now
in India it's far easier to pay in Fiat
to employees as salaries rather than
crypto payment got it and then in terms
of the kind of individual citizen in
India
walk me through a little bit about how
much do they understand about Bitcoin of
cryptocurrency
where does that interest lie today and
kind of like what's the state of kind of
an everyday person in India in
relationship to cryptocurrency if you
think about India that you have to
divide it by you know each groups and if
you look at the whole 18 to 24 25
year-olds I think a lot of them know
about crypto and that's because this age
group is like really active on social
media especially Twitter and Facebook
and they come across Bitcoin somewhere
the other so
this age group and it's also evident
from the data that we have in our user
base this 18 to 25 is like the most
active crypto community in India
it ranges probably right now today about
five to ten million people maybe in
India in this age group understand I
think to be safe let's consider
maybe five million they understand - and
they're in the 8225 the rest of the
people around us when we look at you
know 30 35 40 45 they've all a lot of
them have heard about crypto because of
the whole 2017 bulton that happen the
crypto was all over the media in the
mainstream media and the news channels
beat newspapers everyone knows about
Bitcoin everyone knows there is
something called as crypto currency so
if you were to talk to anyone in India
like the general population which you
know reach news watches Noosa reads
newspapers they will tell you they've
heard of Bitcoin but they have no idea
what it is and similar to the question
you ask a lot of them think it's now
illegal or not allowed to you know trade
in crypto which is the myth that we are
trying to burst by running campaigns
online talking to people doing you know
whatever shows we can getting on our
local news channel if we can so we are
doing that but yeah I think the niche 18
to 25 year olds it deep into technology
and stuff about 5 million people the
completely understand crypto what it is
the good the bad doggy
but the rest I think they've heard of it
but they do not really know what it is
for sure and I mean India is such a
large country right and growing so
quickly that it feels like with things
like deep monetization and other kind of
monetary policy decisions etc that India
would be ripe for adoption of crypto you
think that's accurate or is that kind of
a misplaced perspective from someone who
doesn't look I think these are two
separate things like the whole D
monetization that happened I I don't
think that would be a reason for people
to adopt crypto because that's not
something that it's more of a one-time
event I guess in at least in the last
20-30 years I don't think there's been
an event like that and I don't think
it's going to happen anytime soon again
but in terms of India being
for crypto adoption I think I totally
agree on that and I will tell you why if
you look at the demographic of India a
large population of India probably I
don't know 40 percent or so lips and all
that top tier 1 city is tier 1 tier 2
cities which is like the metros and you
know cities a notch below that and the
this is probably you know you're 300-400
million people or 500 million people and
then there's an equal number of people
or maybe larger will listen to your
three youth cities and villages and
stuff now for banking access you need to
have physical banks present in your
region but India has tens of thousands
of villages and stuff and cities also
which don't have access to these banking
infrastructure people still have to
travel like a long distance to just be
able to open a bank account but most of
these people have access to a mobile
phone today and the internet so if you
come to think about it if there is a way
for these people to just enter you know
the banking system or the financial
system through the internet and true of
mobile phone I think that's why the
revolution has the greatest potential
and this is where you can come in
because crypto is you know instant you
don't have to have your bank account
like your kyc sense of someone's and
then you know probably some person the
city can just instantly send it to a
wallet that you can access from I think
if that part and that's a lot of things
to be done before that is a reality but
I think if this whole access to crypto
gets a mainstream adoption in India I
think none of people will enter the
online financial system in India so I
completely I am a proponent of there
being huge opportunity for people to in
India to get on to crypto there's a need
there's a real need because crypto can
penetrate where banks cannot simply
because India's too big to us
and you know there's a lot of people
around for sure so yeah but I think only
time will tell in the way that I think
about this is very similar to how like
uber is asset light transportation
Airbnb is asked at light hospitality or
hotels Bitcoin and crypto currencies is
basically asset light banking right and
when you think of it that now you start
to see a world where you don't have to
go build that physical bank branch right
you just need somebody to have an
internet connection and if they can get
access to the Internet now you could
give them the full suite of financial
services and as we know by giving
financial services to people you can
create significant inflection points in
their societies and economies right so
it's pretty impact absolutely and you
know one is the reach of crypto which
you know a crypto can reach where the
Internet can it's that simple
but I think that's the other important
piece that you know a lot of people do
not see and it's probably your feel for
India is the access to capital and I've
been a big proponent of this because
look at the world today because of the
internet the access to information has
no geographic boundaries whether you are
in even in the remotest village of India
you can actually come online and get
access to the same kind of education
that someone in the u.s. in the valley
is sitting and getting access to but
that's not true of capital access you
know in like take for example even the
US or even Japan you guys be a really
low rate of interest on capital when you
raise you know when you want to take a
loan for whatever reason in India we
have to pay about 10 to 15 percent rate
of interest for the same capital that
you get access to and I think that if it
this becomes like a fun global financial
system capital costs will come down
considerably for a lot of countries
including India by probably someday we
can dream of getting it at maybe two
percent rate of interest or three
percent rate of interest compared to the
exorbitant cost we are doing today and
that can bring about a massive
transformation in the lives of a lot of
people in this country I think that's
where I'm the most excited about the
access to capital without geography
boundaries
I think crypto can make that happen for
sure and I guess part of this in my
opinion is not only the access to the
the services not only access to cheaper
capital but it's the increase of
accessibility to the global markets as
well right a lot of what you're talking
about is kind of the individual whether
they're in a major city or one of the
towns or villages just getting them
access to banking in general is positive
but if you then can open up the global
access to financial assets and
investment opportunities you can really
start to see wealth generation among you
know billion plus people that have
previously just not had acts absolutely
I mean that's a massive opportunity you
know waiting to be unlocked for sure and
so where did you see that happening
today right I think a lot of people who
look at Bitcoin blockchain
cryptocurrencies etc they say look
there's a lot of promise here right
there's a lot of excitement there's a
lot of hype around this but what's
actually happening today maybe give us
kind of your view obviously you've built
on an exchange and been quite successful
there and we'll get to the finance deal
in a minute but what else is kind of
working in India today around crypto and
what are other products or services that
people are using you want me to say it
specific to India or the global markets
in general I let's do India yeah see I
think India we are probably again a
ground zero level I guess where it's a
nascent ecosystem being built out so the
only way where people are understanding
today I think if we're still at that
level where people are just a custom to
understanding odd crypto is you know
what potential attacks but there's a
small portion of people who are into
these crypto I think lending is like one
of the bigger use cases I'm seeing with
people around me where
they're learning the crypto for a good
rate of return I think I think in
general probably somewhere from five to
ten percent is what you get online train
if you are learning your crypto so
learning is turning out to be a good use
case right now financially in the Indian
ecosystem but it's still very early days
for really like you know I would say the
mixed level of music is probably the
step two for crypto which will only
happen when we have the the piping which
is like the infrastructure level built
out completely I think they're still too
early to get into everyday use cases of
crypto right now it's in the buying
phase accumulation phase that is what is
happening in India right now yeah and to
me what you're talking about is what I
call like the income generation vertical
right where basically if I have an
internet connection and I have any
degree of capital I actually can
generate income without having to go to
work right what I mean by that is I can
participate in lending I can participate
market making I can participate in
staking like there's a whole bunch of
different mechanisms that the crypto
world opens up to me where I can
actually drive cash flow or yield and
and generate this income without having
to go to a nine-to-five desk job and so
those types of opportunities previously
were just unavailable if one you didn't
have access to banking or two you didn't
have access to kind of these income
generating a revenue generating type
mechanism absolutely I mean our income
generation of the you know big news kids
today and I think one of the things I've
missed out is India has a lot of
freelancers and a lot of people who you
know Fork globally I mean they have the
book they get work from anywhere in the
globe and I've heard of a lot of
instances where for them the easiest way
to accept payment was cut because you
know they don't need to sign up on
PayPal and pay a large fee or you know
even receiving foreign
Capital directly into your bank accounts
in India is very hard so this seems to
be like a good way for there are
freelancers to just accept crypto like
you know you're settled within a few
minutes and your bunch of all gets done
so I think that's the other use case
accepting international payments it's
becoming easier for Indians right now
for sure now let's talk about was your
ex and kind of what you guys built there
and then we can get into a by Nance but
but what what exactly have you guys
built from a product standpoint so far
yeah so when we launched in March 2018
the about for I think three weeks after
our launch the whole central bank
banking restrictions came into effect
and we were very new and we were like
you know should we and we got just three
months the bank gave us three months
gave everyone three months to stop you
know working on any Fiat related
businesses to for crypto currency so we
were like you know what are you doing
three months and we started figuring out
because we knew that we do not want to
you know keep our people stranded users
and they don't have an opportunity to
get in and that's when we came across
this whole concept peer-to-peer and it
was not a new concept there have been
other products that do appear to be a
way of buying and selling of crypto but
what we noticed was there was a
significant difference in the way you
traded on a crypto exchange was a
peer-to-peer action like a peer-to-peer
exchange had this traditional classified
kind of made like a Craigslist kind of
way where you put your buy and sell
order somebody comes up and selects it
and then you guys transfer money between
each other and you're done we said that
we wanted to build a peer-to-peer wave
which will give the same experience as
training on a cryptid crypto product
which is you just have an order form by
yourself or you put it you have an order
book and you see the buy and sell beds
you do not have to
any listings and the top bids come at
the best bits come at the top so what we
did is we replicated the crypto crypto
order book but behind the scenes we had
a peer-to-peer system and we launched
this just a day after the banking ban
came into effect and this was for the
first time in the world somebody built a
peer-to-peer auto matching order book
this never existed before be built it
and surprising me you know people in
India loved it because there was no
learning curve anymore you just had to
put your orders instead and as soon as
it matches we just show you a bank
account where you need to transfer the
money so that's all you need to do you
don't have to go through like you know
hundreds of listings of people selling
you bitcoins and going through the
prices mentally making notes on which
prices are the best you don't have to do
any of that you just come here on Wazir
X you put your buy or sell order me show
you the bank account where you need to
transfer the money it was that's that
simple and that really you know like
went crazy like everyone in the country
started signing up that gave us the
massive boost so in a way if you look at
it the adversity turned into an
opportunity for us
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto calm there are crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out tell them pomp
sense you download the app or visit
crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a PlayStation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile
they provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com
tell them pump Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block v
comm / pump again block 5 comm / pump to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today and and how did the
word get out like where you guys was it
just tweeting on Twitter what was there
other things but how did the word spread
what you guys were doing and kind of
with it with the value proposition I
think it's a combination of multiple
stuff like Twitter held the Lord because
I've been you know doing a lot about
crypto blockchain from probably December
or I think October 2017 I started this
whole blockchain tweeting stuff so that
helped me because I had gotten a good
number of crypto audiences like-minded
people on my network on Twitter but I
think word of mouth was turned out to be
the biggest for us where the moment I
started asking people how did you you
know discover was in X they were like
this friend of mine you know just told
me about it because during this time
when the banking ban was happening
another significant thing was happening
in India which was a lot of the older
exchanges the bigger ones were shutting
down because you know some did not build
out this system some could not cope up
with the sudden change
so when businesses were shutting down
every user of that business turn to
their friends to ask them where to go
and
because we build this new craft and
because I as the founder was very open
online on Twitter very responsive to
people which brings a lot of trust I
think that gives the massive push for
both EDX in India for sure and in the
parts of me that I think got me are
really kind of caught my attention and I
start paying attention if you started
using this hashtag India wants crypto
right and I thought that it was a way -
it seemed like you were really kind of
rallying people around that idea but
also you continued to tag was the Prime
Minister Modi and others and really try
to drive the conversation which I
thought was was pretty clever yeah so
that was like the second wave I would
say I started that in November 2018 to
be honest I I never thought I would
continue for so long but you know it's
been now three hundred and ninety days
since I've been tweeting every day and
every day I but my motto is can I with
every tweet that I do can I get two more
people in terms of them understanding or
hearing about Krypton India people in
terms of regular audiences or Newspeak
in you know journalists bloggers anyone
and at the same time there's also hope
that our Prime Minister and our finance
minister who I tagged every day they
look at it and probably you know get in
touch with me or the ecosystem in
general so that we can put a point
across and tell them about crypto not
just being a speculative instrument but
also a create technology that India can
employ in the country so yeah but I
think you're right this has given a
definite boost to my credibility online
my visibility online but that was more
of a side effect of the fact that you
know it was frustrating as an Indian
where India is really good in terms of
Technology India has a lot of
young people millions of youngsters and
yet we do not have like a you know easy
path to crypto adoption or even trying
out crypto I mean imagine if these
barriers did not exist like today it's
just buzzy Rex and you know a few others
but if this barrier did not exist I'm
pretty sure a lot more Indian minds
would be at work on crypto on solving
problems that will actually make the
likes of a billion people better so yeah
I think that is a frustration that led
me to start this campaign and I'm going
to continue till we get some positive
outcome from this from the government's
end for sure and I guess we like what do
you think successes right so you've got
the campaign going but what does success
look like at the end where you would say
you know what we accomplished what we
wanted to yeah
I think the immediate one would be where
government sets a working committee you
know I think I think that's like the
first step to saying okay this is great
because when you if you can set up a
working committee which involves our
lawmakers probably also the ecosystem
there's a bunch of other people together
when you say let's start the
conversation I think even if that
happens I think that's massive success
because then you have a group of people
who can think in the right direction and
take India in the right path took
blockchain and crypto what is happening
today like I said you know at the
beginning of this podcast where we spoke
about the whole committee which came up
with a planning bill that committee had
no representation from the industry it
had no representation from anyone who's
into technology so how do you expect to
come up with any laws or any you know
legality around crypto if you do not
have any technologists or anyone from
the industry to be a part of such a
committee so I think committee formation
or some sort of a working group if the
government can
just you know start a conversation
around that also I think that success
for us
I don't think India will regulate
anytime soon because you know it's a
massive country a lot of capital related
laws in the country to build but you
know Navigator but India can definitely
start a dialogue with industry players
and with technologies and with a bunch
of other people I think that's the first
step for us got it
and then I guess as part of this
obviously the news has now become public
that financed acquired was your ex and
you guys have teamed up to really kind
of push crypto adoption in India maybe
talk to us a little bit about what the
thought process there was from your end
and how that deal came together yeah see
the thing is uh I mean you know pushing
for crypto adoption in India for a long
time now I think at least 12 months but
what I realize is if we wanted to go
faster we want to be able to understand
how this cold crypto I would say the
regulations and you know interactions
and with the government with the
lawmakers how does it book throughout
the globe you know you need someone
who's seen a lot more than you do to be
able to do things faster and that's
where you know I saw finance as being a
good partner that was one aspect the
second aspect was how do I also bring
about faster adoption of crypto in the
country because that was that's my
mission like how do you get everyone in
India to be part of the capital
ecosystem and I think that's where I saw
finance the speed at which I think the
the most attractive thing about by Nance
is the speed of execution if you look at
balance today it's a massive company in
terms of be it your revenue be user.php
it even the number of people they have
over 500 people now but you look at the
way they execute I think you know if I
didn't know I would say it's this
probably a twenty people T because
that's the speed at which I can see
things churning out because as companies
grow I
traditionally always seen the speed
reduces it never increases this out here
you see a company doing the exact
opposite and that I think was the most
attractive thing because speed is what
we need in the crypto ecosystem today we
need to go faster than what we are doing
right now to be able to get you know
such a massive I use a base in india
blick the number of people india if you
want to get to all of them
you need rapid pace and i want to learn
that i want to get all the help I can
and I think finance seemed like that
perfect part of that for sure and so
what's the plan moving forward you
finance and was your all kind of coming
together and going to drive adoption of
crypto and India like how do you do that
together
what's the plan yeah so to start with
fuzzy rakes will continue to be an
independent band in India owned by by
Nance I will continue to run it the way
an but what we'll do now is we'll also
tap into you know the finance network in
terms of finance already has a lot of
engines on them so who always wanted
some Fiat gateway which is accessible
within balance so we'll be integrating a
p2p technology inside finance soon which
will come in q1 or 2020 where you will
be able to like you know get from your
INR
to crypto trading right the Dell finance
taco and that that will give a massive
booth boost and push to buzz erection
shuttle but apart from that I think
Finance has this whole playbook in terms
of how do you increase adoption in
different countries you know in terms of
on-the-ground work as well as online
work so we're going to use a lot of that
expertise to spread the you know word in
India about crypto and spread the
knowledge of crypto in India I think
that's where the significant
contribution from finance will come John
and not to forget the much-needed
capital think about it
you I'm in India in a industry which is
nascent I don't want to be spending my
time running behind capital right now
because I can spend that time you know
getting maybe the next million people on
to crypto so if there is finance I can
just focus on the work ahead rather than
running behind capital now for sure no
mix makes complete sense
and then I guess as part of that how do
you think about expanding your team over
the next 12 to 24 months is it something
where you'll you know grow quite rapidly
or do you think that you'll stay
relatively the same size as you continue
kind of push forward yeah I think you
know it this is something where we have
to spend some time because the finance
you know partnership a lot of synergies
will crop up where we might get to
probably rapid product development
because Finance has a lot of stuff under
the word that we could use so I think
probably in a few months I'll understand
how rapidly we want to scale up in terms
of team size but I think we will
definitely be hiring more probably
increase the team size a bit more but I
don't know exactly right now whether we
want to go for a massive wrap up of
people but I know we want to go for a
massive ramp up of user base that we
will definitely do got it
and then what's your advice there's a
lot of people who are listening to this
that are crypto companies they're
building based some either remotely or
somewhere outside of India and they see
the large population of India as a very
large market and potential user base for
their product what would be your advice
to them as they look to come to India
what's kind of the best way for them to
do that or maybe some of the potholes in
the road that they should try to avoid I
think for projects that want to like you
know target India as a market I think
India relatively
you know it's it's that's to India like
you know one India by child completely
consumes your English information in you
know the English language and the second
India which is very into regional
languages and those are many if you if
you are not natively from this country I
think you can definitely target the
English audience which is also massive
through probably you know a lot of I
would say online work in terms of
spreading the knowledge of your projects
and stuff
through YouTube there are all these
influences I think influences play a
large part in India because ultimately
people trust up you know people from
their country the ones around them so I
think influencer marketing will work
really well in India in terms of you
know outreach and stuff in terms of I
would say product development and
everything I think India has a good you
know number of software developers who
are very very eager to learn how to you
know and want to get into blockchain
development and work on that and in fact
there are a couple I think two or three
good p5 projects out of India as well
and there are a couple of protocols
being built in India so that's
definitely a good you know number of
software developers out here who
competed in the old blockchain book so I
think if you want to build a small you
know Dev Center here I think that's
definitely you can attempt that as well
it's it's a good place for that too but
in terms of your marketing and stuff I
think in India a lot of global marketing
like your influencer marketing SEO you
know your blogs podcasts you know videos
I think those things definitely work for
Indian audiences for sure and then
what's you know it's kind of your
message if you will I think I think I
think you you have a logic
audience from listen man I've told you a
million times I love my brother and I
every year around Christmas time usually
the 20th or 21st of December we pull up
kayaks explore feature and literally
just hit you know go anywhere in the
world and we basically while sitting
there pick a random place in the world
and the rule is that we've got to leave
within 24 hours so it's a pretty planned
trip hunt and I think a lot of people
say okay that you know it's pretty cool
but the key to the trip is when we get
on the plane
we have nothing planned we don't have a
hotel room we don't have any place that
we're gonna go visit we have absolutely
nothing planned and except for the the
amount of time that were likely to spend
there and so December of 2016 is when we
went to India and I remember we landed
at like 1 o'clock in the morning and we
had to figure out to go get a hotel room
and and go through all of this had you
and I were weird going back and forth
think on Twitter then trying to meet up
and you know why don't you come out here
to to the office and I said well the
only way I know how to get there is to
use an uber and I was blown away it was
like $6 in an uber for an hour and a
half ride and came out there and you
know that that very first meeting that
we had kind of set the tone for our trip
and two weeks later we left India after
going to where do we go we went to
Jaipur Agra Delhi Goa a bunch of
different places and I remember when we
left him and I both said that's one of
our favorite places in the world so you
you had more of an impact than you
realize which led to a great trip for us
three years ago that's great I'm happy
to hear that I didn't know that you want
to know the craziest thing that we did
in India yeah and then we rented
motorcycles in Jaipur and rowing by
ourselves each one of us on a separate
motorcycle through all the crazy traffic
in town out to the Monkey Temple out
there and
the best part of the story is it was the
first time that my brother ever drove a
motorcycle so for driving a motor for
the first time is you know already tough
enough to do it in the heart of traffic
but Jaipur is pretty much insane yeah I
think I for those not understanding you
know if they're not from India they
wouldn't understand but driving in India
is a different experience and to be able
to drive motorcycle for the first time
in India I think that's you know hats
off to your brother very proud of that
moment so that's pretty cool what's your
message to to either crypto
entrepreneurs in India or those in India
who are starting to learn about Bitcoin
and cryptocurrency like what you're kind
of you know you've become if not the
leader one of the leaders in India
around this what's kind of your message
to those people I think you know when
you look at crypto if we're at that
stage where nothing's really built out
and you know it's an open playground so
you might be tempted to pick up a lot of
stuff but what you need to see is what
is the immediate next step that needs to
be built in the crypto ecosystem and it
can identify that I think that's massive
success so you know choose what you want
to build there's a lot to be built but
you have to build it in steps you know
and if you can find the next step that
has to be built in probably in India or
probably for the globe you can build it
for anywhere but build what is the
immediate next need of the crypto
ecosystem you will find success yeah for
sure and then what's your message to two
regulators government officials central
bankers in India I think you know when
we come across a very disruptive
radically new technology the first thing
will always be to look at all the
negative stuff that is possible and this
would have been true even though the
internet in the early days when people
thought a lot of bad things could be
done on the internet but after probably
2025 years of you know internet rapid
internet adoption in India the amount of
good
Internet dead far surpasses the amount
of bad that happens which is the same
case with Qatar we need to look at you
know probably there are 80 good things
that crypto can bring and there might be
20 bad things we can always regulate and
handle the bad things but the good has
to really be encouraged and I think
India is primed for that crypto
encouragement now and I want the
regulator's to come and you know discuss
this with us so that we can figure out
how to probably amplify the good and
defuse the bad stuff of crypto
absolutely it's excellent before I wrap
up I always ask a rapid-fire set of
questions what do you think is the most
important company in crypto other than
your own I think a lot of I don't want
to name one but a lot of companies in
the defy space I think very exciting
because that's that's like the future I
think the defy ecosystem being built out
right now it's very exciting for sure
and just as a side note has cz been to
India that he comes visit in person um
as far as I know I don't think so I
don't think he's been to India I can't
remember but I don't think so but yeah I
think it's it's about time here he has
come to India maybe that's the next
campaign is bring cz - I think what is
what's the number one regulation that
you would change or improve whether it's
in India or globally to kind of assure
an adoption I think you know probably as
I think the facets would be crypto
sandbox in every country
just let them build what they want the
sandbox had control it if you want just
see that experiment play out I think
that's very important I love that idea
and obviously encouraging the innovation
experimentation is super valuable what's
your most controversial thought in
crypto like what's the thing you believe
that everyone else will disagree with
you on
I think I don't talk about this but I
think they will come at you know all
this whole VP are income taxes we be on
be everything is very bound to our
country but I think a day will come
where all this whole income tax and
everything it'll all disappear because
it will be very hard to enforce and
country will start charging you sort of
a rent for being in that country so you
know the whole income tax ecosystem in
the way it works taxation and stuff will
change to rent where you pay the country
because you are in that country and you
stay there as a person I think that's
what I radically think will happen in
the future
got it what's the best book you've ever
read or your favorite book you've ever
read the book I think I've loved a lot
of them but the very early my life I
read The Godfather and I think the you
know the the p22 business ethics of
business the be you two things I think I
learned a lot from the Godfather but
there was very early in my life I was in
probably school or college early days
yeah I love that
what do you thing about aliens real you
believe in them I definitely do I am
because I just don't think that the
universe being this big it's just going
to be us in there it's just probably you
haven't found a way to communicate but
we will do you think that we discover
them or they discover us first I think I
think we will discover them I'm certain
you be at least I think we are more
advanced than the rest of the it is OPI
yeah at least for us we better hope we
all right yeah
our definition of Pi I'll let you ask me
one question what you got for me I got
to you know the first is when are you
coming to India next what am i coming
next so I haven't told very many people
this but I'm trying to come next year
2020 I haven't picked the dates yet but
there's a couple of conferences that
have asked me to come so I'm trying to
figure out which one I can make work
with my schedule but I am
confident I'm gonna end up coming in
2020 so I'll let you and everyone else
know when when that's gonna be awesome
the other question is what do you think
will be the like the you know every year
I've seen is some new trend in crypto
and this year I think was more about a
lot of stable coins Levi's and all this
nice what do you think is 2020 going to
yeah it's great question so I think that
there's probably three things one is
you'll see a continuation of like the
digitization of fiat currencies so
governments and central banks will start
like doubling and tripling down on this
idea like let's digitize the dollar the
the law net cetera to is the
tokenization of debt so whether it is
governments or corporations or
asset-backed securities etc I think
you're gonna start to see a lot more of
that happening I mean kind of the
automation of that entire industry and
then the third thing is I think that
you're gonna see a world where we start
to get some bifurcation so right now
it's kind of like there's Bitcoin and
then there's everything else I think
what you're gonna start to see is
there's Bitcoin then there is like the
[ __ ] coins but in between there is a
very small number of high-quality very
thoughtful uses of tokens
what those are and which ones yet I
probably don't have an opinion or want
to speculate on but I do think that
we're gonna start to see you know kind
of a higher degree of success or higher
quality on use cases for some of these
tokens and so what it'll do is I think
it'll really kind of show a difference
between the high quality ones and the
low quality ones and so when that
happens I think that it'll kind of
vindicate some of the people who are big
believers in whether its web 3 or defy
all of those kinds of of bents on the
blockchain world but but we had just
haven't seen yet kind of the major use
cases for many of those tokens so if we
that'll happen in 2020 as well
interesting so you mean don't say
there's going to be a
middle category like a pvp [ __ ] corner
and then in between that's going to be
probably we need a new term for that yes
so like here would be a great example
right so uh I'll throw cz a bone on this
one let's say that there's Bitcoin then
there is all of the [ __ ] coins and then
like part of the middle group let's put
b and b there for now right and why is
being be interesting
well if finance can actually go from
being in exchange to a true global bank
that provides all kinds of different
financial services to folks and then can
eventually decentralize themselves on
the corporate structure side to the
point where the equity either one
doesn't exist or two is worthless and
all of the value accrues to the b-and-b
token through the burning mechanism all
of a sudden what you do is if you want
to own a kind of financial exposure to
buy Nantz you have to buy the token
right and so like that's a really
interesting kind of evolution for both b
and b but also for finance and so you
know there's some work that's got to be
done to kind of get to that point but i
think that they're kind of headed in
that direction and so if they're able to
be successful there like that goes you
know kind of in a category that isn't
bitcoin obviously and also is in the
[ __ ] coin so we kind of need a third
category but I don't think that category
is going to be you know filled with
hundreds of tokens I think it's gonna be
quite small I would put it you know
twenty or less that end up kind of
figuring out the right model and value
accrual but but definitely B&B is one of
them that has a shot and then there's
probably others as well
that'll kind of create this third
category yeah I think that's a very
interesting proposition and I think
that's where even if you know even CDs
spoke about this a few times where the
eventual goal is to decentralized and
have PNP s like the only entry and exit
point for you to participate in that
only you know ecosystem I think that'd
be very interesting to see for a lot
more projects you know that happened in
the ecosystem let's see for sure where
can where can people find you on the
internet and also was your ex I'm on
mr. Shetty is my handle Twitter handle
and fuzzy X you can just go to was he
likes calm and start trading if you're
in India Bitcoin is a Bitcoin nav and
the crypto is not illegal living there
so you can participate in the crypto
ecosystem if you're reading the if
you're listening to this and haven't yet
done it I think now it's time I love it
man I love it we'll keep fighting the
good fight and spreading a kind of the
the gospel of Bitcoin and crypto you're
doing a fantastic job I want to do this
again in the future to get an update on
how things in India are gone
sure thanks a lot for having me I think
a lot I've also learned following you on
Twitter and I know having known you I
think it's a it's it's a weird path we
both ended up in the whole same
ecosystem all over again it's a small
small world but it's been fun right yeah
yeah I talk soon hey everyone pop here
if you like this episode of off the
chain and want to help us take crypto to
the top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way in helping us take the entire
crypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts I appreciate you listening and
see you next time on off the chain